I recently watched all of the MCU movies
back-to-back in chronological order for
the first time my eyes were opened to
exactly what makes them so good and why
every other shared Universe film
franchise seems to fail
seeing Thor and Thor the dark world for
the first time allowed me to make subtle
connections between the collection that
I'd previously missed when watching the
film's theatrically and the reason for
their success became glaringly apparent
DC recently tried to mimic Marvel's
success with Justice League however upon
its release it was met with harsh
reviews by critics and at this moment it
is struggling at the box office but why
on paper it shares several similarities
with the Avengers they are both a
super-powered group led by a human
billionaire who seeks to stop the
destruction of the earth at the hands of
an otherworldly being wielding a
mystical weapon of mass destruction
however where they differ clearly isn't
that apparent to many especially Warner
Brothers over the past two years we've
heard rumors about Warner Brothers
trying to brutally alter the production
of Justice League and when watching the
film the disjointed plot and reshoots
stand out more than Henry cobbles
Photoshop mouth bringing in Joss Whedon
director of The Avengers seemed like a
smart move but not even the acclaimed
filmmaker was able to save the
production this is in my opinion due to
studio interference DC have began a
retroactive layout of the look of Batman
V Superman brightening it up to appear
similar and aesthetic to Iron Man and
the ilk recent streams on iTunes have
shown that Warner Brothers have
drastically altered the look and feel of
the film and it seems like everything is
going a bit George Lucas this production
operation method has carried over a
Justice League and when we compare the
first trailers films to the final car
it's obvious that a lot of scenes were
reshot and daylight to appear brighter
it's only upon analysis of this that you
realize that DC and similar shared
universe franchises have no idea what
they are doing fact of the matter is the
Marvel movies aren't critically and
commercially successful because they
have quips and up
right it's because they have a
consistent tone throughout the film and
focus on character development above all
else DC have already shown with the Dark
Knight trilogy that they can make films
that are dark grounded and not child
friendly and still turn a huge profit
so it seems baffling that they want to
shy away from this in order to offer an
inferior carbon copy of their
competitors
honestly I don't buy Marvel films that
funny and the fact that I can see
everything that's going on in a scene
doesn't make them any more endearing
whilst Batman V Superman had problems it
still felt all part of one piece and
whilst the were issues overall I felt
the film did a great job of painting how
the world would react in fear to a
superhuman visitor DC took a gamble and
whilst it didn't pay off due to their
restrictions on the runtime theatrically
upon release on home video as an
extended cut many seemed to appreciate
the film or switch over to Suicide Squad
in Justice League where the backpedaling
began these films are a mess designed by
committee they aim to please to many
people and in doing so please non there
is no consistent vision and the dynamics
of the movie jump from one foot to the
other trying to impress an audience that
will most likely end up bored watching
the Marvel movies concurrently made me
realize that you could stop Ironman one
switch the disc over and begin watching
Captain America the Winter Soldier and
tonally nothing would seem amiss they
all appear to be part of the same vision
and could easily happen within the same
space DC can't even keep this
consistency up scene to scene let alone
movie to movie and it's the main reason
that fans have no idea what was going on
with the universe looking back at
Justice League I would rather have had
the full Snyder car with junkie XL
scoring the action in all its grandiose
and flawed beauty than a mash-up between
x-men and the Avengers films not
everything has to be bright and colorful
and not everything should be DC fans
such as myself gravitate towards the
publisher because of their dark nature
that always feels like this
thing lurking in the shadows there so
it's disappointing that what I love
about their universe is being dismantled
in favor of an aesthetic that the
characters aren't built for gone are the
days when films were made one by one
missing is the care and attention put
into each release replaced with a slate
that is solely there to excite farm boys
it's style of a substance
leaping with nowhere to land putting the
cart before the horse and planning to
fail movie studios need to realize that
in order to have a shared universe they
have to build one first not have one
before construction has even began if I
want to watch a Marvel movie I'll watch
a Marvel movie and that's why everything
else simply pales in comparison thanks
very much for taking the time to check
out my video I hope you enjoyed it
because I put a lot of work into it I'm
gonna be running lots of video essays
like this from time to time so make sure
that you subscribe to the channel and
check out my review on the Dark Knight
Returns which I've just released I'm
also doing a podcast called watching The
Watchmen with my friend Tom Queen and we
read through each issue individually
deciphering the meanings and analyzing
the themes behind Alan Moore's work and
it's definitely worth checking out once
again thanks very much for watching this
video hopefully I'll see you next time
take care
peace